undoubtedly his greatest contributions
were in the field of psycho history
selden found the field little more than
a set of vague axioms
he left it a profound statistical
science the best existing authority we
have for the details of his life is the
biography written by gal dornick who as
a young man
met seldon two years before the great
mathematician's death
the story of the meeting encyclopedia
galactica
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
look at this old foundation teaser and
try to break it down
because i just re-read the whole series
and i'm kind of fascinated to see how
they try to adapt it
the original foundation series by isaac
asimov
first released as short stories
published in the 1940s
then collected and published in a
trilogy of novels in the 1950s
is a classic by any definition it's set
more than 21
000 years in the future it has this
amazing scope
that includes a galactic empire of more
than 25 million worlds
that's made possible by hyperspatial
travel
and i mean this series basically
influenced all of the most popular
sci-fi you're familiar with
at the same time it's a really tough
adaptation because it's missing most of
the key ingredients that we expect in a
television series
i think the biggest obstacle is that the
story takes place over a thousand years
characters come and go they never really
get developed and in a way that's what
we watch tv
for spoilers-wise i'm gonna give you
background information about what the
story is about the kind of stuff you'd
learn from reading a blurb about the
show
or the stories that it's based on i'm
not gonna get into what happens at the
end
with that out of the way let's look at
what we see going off the casting
announcements
and footage they use here to me it looks
like they're going to focus on the
initial two or three stories in the
first book for season one that seems
like a good idea considering how fast
time passes in the series
we're introduced to gal dornick who's
boarding a transport ship on her home
world of cinex
and we get a look at several shots of
her leaving cut throughout the teaser
gal's a mathematician that's described
as a country boy
obviously the show did a gender swap
here and she's heading to the empire's
capital of trantor for the first time
in the voice over we hear her say only
we can shorten the darkness
and i'll come back to that in a bit we
also get our first look at harry selden
played by jared harris who looks like
he's being arrested or something along
those lines he looks kind of dirty and
disheveled here
which means they might be adding some
scenes that lead up to
an appearance in court he has in the
books there's an unknown character
looking at this dark landscape with
fires burning in the distance
this isn't anything you would recognize
from the first book but this might be
tied into some of the stuff that we
learn about the planet of trantor
in the prequels that they put out years
after the original trilogy
if i was forced into guessing what this
is i would say it probably has something
to do with powering the planet trantor
and that this character may have been
added as someone who's working with
selden who can serve as a companion for
gal
on her trip from trantor to terminus
there's a handful of mysterious space
shots that could be anything
this one that looks really cool could
possibly be related to hyperspace since
they're gonna have to set that up
and somewhat explain how people move
around the galaxy so fast
there's another unknown character at
night with something like a lantern
if i had to guess about this i would say
that this is either this character's
home world
or more likely the world the psycho
historians get exiled to which is called
terminus
there's a native creature that comes out
of the dark and it's all probably
related to adding depth to the world
building
this all goes back to what i was saying
in the beginning most of what we learn
about the galactic
empire and all of its worlds and systems
and everything else that's going on
in this huge story we find out through
conversations with two people in a room
so the tv series is gonna have to show
us all this stuff we can't have a bunch
of exposition
dumps so it makes sense for us to see a
lot of different stuff
to flesh out the world that doesn't
necessarily come from the early stories
in the book
we see the interior of a ship it's
probably the same one gal was boarding
heading to trantor
this looks pretty great and it looks
like you can see the approach to trantor
through the window you sort of see a
planet come into view
then there's this showrunner interview
with david goyer
which really feels kind of unnecessary
in relation to the show
there's some interesting behind the
scenes shots here but all it really
serves to do is make it clear that
they're not holding back budget-wise
and trying to realize this thing there's
not a whole lot of actual footage in
this trailer
most likely because the pandemic shut
down production
so i guess they wanted to come out with
something here and they threw this
in as a way to introduce the series
after that we get a closer look at
trantor
we see a tower coming off the surface of
the planet into space
and this appears to be a scene taken
directly from the beginning of the first
book
after gal arrives she wants to see what
the planet looks like
so she takes an elevator ride to an
observation deck one thing that stood
out to me on this reread was that
in this first story the planet trantor
is actually the main character
yeah we do meet harry selden we get an
idea of what psycho history is
but gal coming from her home planet and
seeing this
massive crazy capital city slash
planet for the first time trantor is
amazing
and i could definitely make a whole
video about it but what's important for
this video is to say that it gives us a
really good idea of what the galactic
empire is like
so there's a lot of potential to see a
lot of really cool stuff in this first
season
and it's probably what i'm most excited
about as far as the visuals are
concerned
after that we see gal being led into the
university where selden works on the
psycho history project
and this looks like it leads to their
formal introduction
harry selden says they're going to
arrest me tomorrow
and gal looks pretty disappointed about
the circumstances here
especially when she finds out she's
probably getting arrested too he asked
if she's familiar with his work
she says in theory and he quickly
corrects her saying it's not a theory
so the premise of the story is that this
guy harry selden
has created this field of psycho history
which is able to use mathematics to
predict where things are going basically
it doesn't work on the level of
individuals but it is able to look at
big
groups of people and come to conclusions
about where
society is headed he's been working on
it for a long time
and he's come to the conclusion that not
only will the empire fall
that trantor itself will fall but that
that's going to lead to
30 000 years of barbarism basically
everything's gonna go backwards
and at this point he doesn't believe
that can be stopped but if they apply
this science of psycho history
make their decisions based on what it
tells them
then they can shorten that period of
time from 30
000 years down to 1 000 years and then
a better second empire can emerge and
put things on the right path
galdornik had no idea she just got her
phd
she's just coming to the big city for
the first time from her little home
planet in the middle of nowhere and now
she's getting hit with the idea that her
new boss is getting arrested she's
getting arrested too
and as it's mentioned in the blurb i
opened the video with she'll find out
her job is to actually
help move the project to its new center
which is going to be on an insignificant
mostly uninhabited planet called
terminus
on top of everything else he's learning
one of the key axioms of
psycho history is that people can't know
what it predicted
ahead of time they just basically have
to follow the plan
if everyone knew what was supposed to
happen then that would change things it
kind of makes sense right
so gal doesn't exist in the story for a
long time but she does have an important
role
as does this other character we meet in
the trailer
salver hardin we see her which is
another instance of gender swapping
hardin was a man in the story he was the
first mayor of terminus
the foundation's homeworld part of
harry's plan was to send
galdornik to set things up there and
because things are headed towards
barbarism
the idea is that he's sending a bunch of
scientists
who can collect all the important
knowledge and create the encyclopedia
galactica a way for humanity to retain
all the important things it's learned at
the height of the galactic empire
we see salver in a couple of shots here
i guess that these are on
terminus but again this could be her
homeworld giving us an
idea of where she comes from who she is
as a character
i guess i should mention all the gender
swapping
most of these characters aren't fleshed
out in the books so they could be male
or female it doesn't make a big
difference
and to be honest there really aren't any
women in the first book so it's probably
a good idea to add some here and there
the other thing we see on trantor is the
emperor he's credited as playing brother
day
there's a brother dusk whose description
says he's the oldest member of the royal
family
and a brother dawn who we see a couple
of times and this isn't something that
comes from the books
what we do know about the emperor at
this time is that he's in charge
of a dying empire and at this point he's
not really that powerful
things are really under the control of
the aristocrats that are around him
and essentially the emperor and the
people around him holding on to power
is a big factor in why the empire can't
save itself
there's definitely a lot of potential
for interesting stuff there
but the actual stories they move away
from trantor
and the empire recedes into the
background for quite a few
years so it'll be interesting to see
what they do i imagine
introducing this brother dawn character
a young member of the royal family
sets up his return as an adult in some
of the later stories
since everyone we meet at the very
beginning won't live very long
into that 1000 year plan the show could
play around with it a little bit
and you think that they might
considering they cast jared harris and
lee pace here
but they've also said that they plan on
doing the whole story
if they get the chance something like
eight seasons and
80 episodes so they can't really linger
on the origins that much
overall this trailer looks fantastic it
looks like they're really going out of
their way to make this a beautiful
looking series
and as a fan of the original stories i
really hope that they're able to do that
it really won't be easy the book as it
is is strange by today's standards but
it's really effective at doing what it
does
you could tell that asimov is very
interested in making sure it's clear
what he's trying to say
and as i mentioned that definitely comes
down to people talking to each other
explaining things to each other over and
over really
and that's just not something that
naturally translates to
long-form tv there is one other thing
that is in this trailer that really
stands out but it's one of those things
that i can't really say anything about
there's another character here who's a
part of the series but doesn't play a
part in the first book
edo dimersal this is another gender swap
but i really don't know how they're
integrating this right here at this
point
i have theories based on what i know
about the ending of the series
but i don't think that we should get
into that in this video
we also see some action sequences here
and that's another thing that is missing
from this series as far as the books are
concerned there's virtually no action
sequences throughout the entire thing
so it does make sense that the show will
add those in there
to keep people interested so there's a
lot of potential
i hope it's realized i'd love to hear
what you think
if you're a big fan of the series i
think that you would agree with
me that in most cases when you think of
an adaptation you want it to be as close
as it can be to the source material but
this is a really strange case where i
think that that would actually be
terrible
so let me know if you think they can
pull it off what you're hoping they'll
be able
to get through what you're hoping to see
and really any worries that you have
the thing about foundation is the selden
plan and the foundations
are necessary according to psycho
history and psycho history is based on
irrefutable
science the idea that nobody can know
why they're doing what they're doing
makes things really interesting
but it doesn't necessarily make the
strong case that this is the way
it has to be what i like about these
books is that you fill in so much of the
blanks yourself with your own
imagination
in the way you kind of create everything
around the periphery
and you can focus in on the
philosophical
the ideas it's really a series about
ideas
that's where it's strongest in the fall
of an empire you know it's a good time
to think about that
i guess what it'll come down to is can
they make it compelling tv
and will where their imaginations go be
the same as where ours did when we read
it for the first time
i think that's a good place to leave it
i could definitely do some more
foundation
background videos i'm not sure if
there's any interest for it right now
but we'll see what happens with this one
for the last few weeks i've been
immersed so i've been thinking about all
this stuff
i just don't know if anybody's going to
be watching these at this time
so let me know what you think in the
comments please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon
you